[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT KUBIS: What I'm
going to talk today about
is best practices on
migrating to Cloud Spanner.
And I'm Robert Kubis.
I'm the lead advocate for the
storage and database system
for the Google Cloud Platform.
You can find me on Twitter
under the name @hostirosti
if you'd like to chat with me
or send me feedback or anything.
First of all, I
want to point out
that we have a Dory
for this session.
I saw already one
question was put on there.
So please feel free to
put questions on there,
and we will try to answer them
throughout the conference.
So please check back if
you've asked a question,
and we will answer them there.
I might actually also
pick one or two questions,
if I have time at the
end, from the Dory.
We will see.
So before I start and
go and dive into it,
I would like to understand
what my audience is.
So who of you here has already
played with Cloud Spanner?
OK, quite a bit.
Who is in production
with Cloud Spanner?
There are a few.
Cool.
For all the others, thank
you for joining, definitely.
And everybody, thank
you for joining.
This session is actually
aimed as, like, in-between.
So I'm not going to talk about
the basics of what Spanner is,
but I will mention
here and there
if it helps for
the understanding.
So here are the things that
I'm going to cover today.
And so for the ones
that are in production,
it might be that a lot of the
things that I talk about today
are things that
you already know.
And there might even
maybe nothing new,
maybe there is something new.
So please don't be disappointed
going out of this talk.
I want to set the expectations
right in the beginning.
So if you think this is maybe
not what you were looking for,
I don't hold it to you if you
look for a different session.
So today we're
going to go through
pretty much three stages.
First, I want to
talk about if you
plan to move to
Spanner, primarily
if you're coming from
another, for instance,
relational database system
or a NoSQL database system.
So what are the differences of
traditional database systems,
traditional or DBMS,
to Cloud Spanner,
and what to look out for.
Number two, I will talk
about the move of your data.
So how do you get data
quickly into Cloud Spanner?
And how would you
design the system
where you actually have
to move from one database,
and you want to have your
application either running
throughout the transition,
or where you can actually
accommodate some downtime,
and how you would do that.
And number three is I'm
looking a little bit
in a couple of monitoring,
inspection, and optimizing
aspects.
So this will mostly
focus on the things
that we see very, very often
in terms of what customers
are reporting to us, where
they are having challenges
to get the best performance
out of Cloud Spanner.
And last but not
least, I will mention
a couple of very
interesting sessions that
are actually still coming up,
which I encourage you to go to.
So one slide-- what
is Cloud Spanner?
So we say it's the
best of two worlds
of the relational semantics
and having horizontal scale.
So there's a lot
of technology going
on underneath Cloud Spanner
which makes that possible.
Traditionally, if you look at
horizontally scaling databases,
there are two basically flavors.
Either you go and sacrifice some
of the relational semantics,
and with this the
consistency constrains,
or you might end up with a
lot of conflict resolution,
where maybe a system that you
have to particular co-locate
to get a good
performance out of it
because of the communication
that is necessary to ensure
the strong consistency.
Now, under Cloud Spanner,
there is a system
called TrueTime, which
allows us to remove
some of the communication
necessary to ensure
strong consistency.
So let's dive into the
planning aspect of it.
So if you look at
traditional database,
traditional
relational databases,
and that is usually
a single-host system.
So they are vertical, scalable.
If you need more power,
you put more CPUs in,
you put more main memory
in, but at some point,
there is a ceiling what
you can scale vertically.
Now, in these
single-host systems,
over the last 40,
50 years by now,
they have a lot of cool
features developed,
but which are
specifically tailored
for a single-host
system, and which
are detrimental to a
system which you distribute
horizontally over multiple
machines, even zones
and regions.
So some of them I mention here.
So if you look at
traditional databases,
you have things like value
constraints, you can check,
you can do foreign
key constraints.
And with this
referential integrity,
you have sequences, which you
can use for your primary key,
for instance, and it's
nothing bad to use them.
It's actually sometimes
really helpful
to use these sequences
in single-host systems.
You have possibilities
for user-defined functions
to do verification, to do type
conversion, things like that.
You have stored procedures where
you can put business logic in.
And you have triggers
where you can basically
trigger certain
processes asynchronously
over multiple tables, or even
synchronously if you want to.
And then also a
feature which is very
common in traditional
databases is
that you have very fine,
granular permission systems.
So most databases support
permission systems
on databases, on
tables, and then there
are a few that go down to row
or even cell level permission
systems in your database.
Now, how does this
compare to Cloud Spanner?
Number one, you
have no sequences.
So the way that Cloud
Spanner is storing data
is we basically order the
table alphanumerically
by the primary key,
and then we partition
or we split this
table up, and we
move these splits
to different hosts
to be responsible
for these splits.
Actually, it's not one
host that is responsible.
It's a Paxos group
that is responsible.
So it's three machines,
usually three machines,
that are responsible for one
split, which is basically
a part of your table.
Now, since we are ordering
them alphanumerically
by the primary key, if
you would use a sequence
as a primary key,
you can imagine
that new data would always
be appended at the end,
so it always goes
to the same split.
And by having only one split be
responsible for all the load,
you run into hotspotting,
because only one in one Paxos
group is responsible
for that one split,
and so the boundaries
of your scalabilities
are basically what you
can put in terms of load
onto this split and
these machines that
are working on that.
We have also now things like
foreign key constraints,
because they can
be really expensive
if you need to do
these verification
of referential integrity
across multiple splits,
maybe even across
multiple regions.
So we have something
which is kind
of a foreign key constraint
minus, minus, which
we call interleaved tables.
So you can actually interleave
a table into another table.
Because they are living
on the same split,
we can actually do this
referential integrity there,
and we can do things like delete
on cascade and stuff like that.
Another thing that
we don't currently
support in Cloud
Spanner are things
like triggers,
stored procedures,
and user-defined functions.
All these things have
to basically move up
into your application layer
to have the same functionality
for your application
if you want to move
from a traditional database
system to Cloud Spanner.
And then the next
thing is the user
permission systems that we
support on Cloud Spanner
is currently on
the database level.
So you can create
a service account
and can give a database
write and read levels,
but you can't go
any lower than that.
So all the user
control that you have,
all the access control that
you want to support, again,
needs to move into
your application layer.
There are a couple of
other things to mention.
So if you look, for
instance, at the data
types that Cloud
Spanner supports,
there is a good
variety of data types.
But we hear, loud and clear,
and we are looking into that
and working on it to
support a numeric type.
Especially a numeric type
for financial applications,
also scientific
applications, where
you need a lot of
accuracy and precision,
a numeric type is
basically something
what you want to have in your
database natively supported.
Currently, we don't support it.
So our advice, if you
move from a system
which imports a numeric
type to Cloud Spanner
to store these things in string.
Float and integer will not
give you enough precision
unless you are basically
distributing your numerics
across multiple integers
or multiple floats.
Again, this also is in line
with the node sequences.
If you look at the primary keys,
to enable the distribution,
to enable the
horizontal scale, you
want to have very
well-distributed primary keys.
So if you come from MySQL or
PostgreSQL or any of the larger
third-party databases
that are out there,
and you're using
something like a sequence
or you're using
continuous generated key
for your primary keys, you
need to basically modify that.
So use something like UUID
version 4, or prefix your key
with something which
is well-distributed.
Another important thing to
look at in Cloud Spanner
is that advanced structures,
like indexes, for instance,
are actually mapped
back to basic structures
in Cloud Spanner.
So indexes are
just normal tables
in our back end [INAUDIBLE],,
which you don't see as such.
You see them as indexes,
but we are actually
handling them as tables.
And this is important here.
If you look at
traditional databases
and you look at
indexes, how they work,
you basically build up, usually
like a HashMap or something,
where you can go
do an index scan.
And if you find your key or
what you're looking for, and you
want to map the row
against the-- like,
get some other data out of
your base table for that index
lookup--
you basically just do a
jump either in memory,
or you know where it
is located on disk,
and you map that
into your memory,
and then basically
can directly access
the data of your base table.
Now, since data is
distributed in Cloud Spanner,
we don't have these advantages
on that level for lookups.
You can't just go to a
different memory location
on a different host to do
the lookup of the base table
data for a certain row.
So what actually happens
is you do the index lookup.
It's just a table, basically.
And then if you don't have
the data in your index
that you actually want to
access with your query,
you do have to do a back-join
into the base table.
And a back-join in a distributed
system can be very expensive.
So be aware of this, that
if you create indexes,
and you want to actually have
some that are providing you
the data that qualifies
for the query,
there are capabilities to
store that data with the index,
so it's basically stored
in the same table,
and so you do not need
to do the back-joins.
So what are the
workloads, four of them,
which are fitting well
onto Cloud Spanner?
So one of them is,
if you have already
a sharded relational
database system,
you're probably already in the
weeds of managing this, looking
at how you shard, maybe you
do have to repartition things,
stuff like that.
So it's usually a lot of work
to do these sharded systems.
But because you have a sharded
system, many of the things
that I mentioned earlier, like
UDFs or stored procedures,
you might already
not using anymore,
because they don't work well
in these sharded systems.
So you might have gotten
rid of these things
already in your database layer
and have moved them already
to the application layer.
So if that is the case, the
transition and migration,
the move to Cloud Spanner, might
be much, much easier for you.
Another thing is if you are
at the edge of scalability,
I mentioned, if you're at the
edge of vertical scalability,
and you want to
basically consider
to move into a NoSQL
world because you need
the horizontal scale, that is
also a good use case where you
can look into Cloud Spanner.
You keep the
relational semantics,
but you get the horizontal
scale on top of it.
The third one is manageability
and high availability.
So if you have a system
where you run, for instance,
your master and then
multiple failover systems
because you need to be high
available in case of there is
any data corruption or
machine fault or anything,
and you failover to
a different machine,
you usually get
some offline time
during that process to
failover and to catch up
on locks and things like that.
So this is a case, also, which
is a very good case for using
Cloud Spanner, because it's
distributed by default.
It's high available by default.
You have the regional instances
with four nines of availability
and the multi-region instances
with five nines of availability.
And with the five
nines of availability
comes the multi-region
capability of Cloud Spanner.
So we have configurations
where your data
lives in multiple regions that
we support at Google Cloud
regions.
And the responsibility
for data elements
is basically moved
between these two regions.
And then if one region
fails, all the responsibility
for that data moves
to the other region.
And your data-- your
database lives on
is still accessible
from that other region.
So what are things that don't
fit well on Cloud Spanner?
So if you are heavily invested
with stored procedures, UDFs,
things like that into your
traditional database system,
and you want to basically pick
it up and drop it onto Cloud
Spanner, you won't be happy.
There will be a
lot of challenges.
It might actually not even
work for various reasons.
So lift and shift is not really
a thing for Cloud Spanner.
It is a lift and re-platform,
re-applicate, basically.
Another thing is if you're
using your application,
like ORM and things like
that, we are looking
and we are investing
into ORM support.
But at the moment, we don't
have a lot of ORM support.
So if you look
into compatibility
of what you have on
traditional database systems,
in terms of library, that is
just not in that state yet
for Cloud Spanner.
And then if you look
into applications
where you need really,
really low latencies,
like single-digit
milliseconds or even down
to the nano and
microseconds, that's
also not an application
for Cloud Spanner because
of the nature that we
focus on, high availability
and manageability.
And so the way that Cloud
Spanner is built underneath
to have the durability
of your data just
doesn't allow for the very
low single-digit millisecond
latencies.
So another thing
that you don't want
to do with Cloud Spanner,
which I added there
on the fourth point,
is Cloud Spanner
is not an all-app database.
So if you do heavyweight
analytical queries,
you will run into problems.
It will be painful, and
you won't be happy with it.
So for that, I
encourage everybody
to look into BigQuery
or even Bigtable.
If you have something
that you need a little bit
more real-time analytics, look
into these two storage systems
that we have available
as well to help you
with your analytical needs.
So just kind of in summary,
what are the things
that you want to look
at if you do your schema
migration from your
old application
on a traditional database
system to Cloud Spanner?
So if you have monotonic
keys, prefix them,
use well-distributed keys, and
use interleaving carefully.
So as mentioned,
interleaved tables
are ending up in the same
split as the parent row.
So if you have a lot of load
on an interleaved table for one
row of your parent table, you
basically go to one split,
and so you are in danger of
hotspotting to that split.
In terms of indexes,
again, what we
see a lot is that
customers are basically
looking at the schema.
They're fixing
their primary keys.
They are happy.
Everything is great.
And then you create an
index on the updated row
or on the insert row
or insert time row.
So as mentioned, an
index is also a table.
And if you create an index
on a monotonic field,
you run into the
exact same problems.
So be aware of this,
that indexes behave
the same as your tables, and
you need to pay attention
to what you use as your
primary key for your tables
as well as for your indexes.
And then if you
have things like--
an example is a social network.
You already have
a really hot key.
There is one popular person,
which everybody wants
to know something about it.
Consider replicating and
duplicating that key,
and build the logic around
that into your application
to make sure that it's still
strong, consistent, updated
across all your replicas.
So another thing-- what is
very common, what we see
is that there are 10 tables
created during runtime,
or anything kind of like
schema changes very often done.
New applications are
deployed very frequently.
And with every
application deployment,
there is a schema change.
So you have to be careful
with schema changes.
And Cloud Spanner supports
online schema changes.
So you don't have any
downtime that you experience
if you do a schema change.
But we keep schemas
around for around an hour.
And the reason is you
can actually travel back
in time with Cloud Spanner.
These are called
time-bounded reads, which are
used for backups, for instance.
But also if you want to use a
little bit less locks and less
contention, you can do
time-bounded reads or
time-bounded queries.
So be aware of that, that if
you do a lot of schema changes,
that they basically stack up.
And we keep them all
in memory, and that
puts a lot of memory
pressure on our system.
So use them wisely
and use them sparsely.
Try to aggregate
your schema changes.
As mentioned there, schema
changes are serialized.
So they're put on a
stack and then rolled out
after each other.
And they are transactional.
So we basically do
all the schema changes
in the background.
And then once the
new schema is ready,
we flip it over
with a transaction.
And any transactions
that are in flight,
which would span two
versions of the schema,
we basically just abort it
and rerun that transactions.
And then for schema
changes, if you
have new indexes
that you create,
these indexes can take days
even if you backfill that index
from very large tables.
So be aware of that as well.
So with all the things, all
the constraints, and all
the challenges that
Cloud Spanner has,
if you move onto
Cloud Spanner, there
are some good things about it.
There are actually a
lot of good things.
I am working on Cloud Spanner
for two and a half years now.
It is definitely one of
my favorite products.
I have a lot of fun
playing with it.
Benefit given, I don't have to
pay out of my pocket for it.
But it is a lot of
fun to play with it.
So what do you get, actually,
if you move onto Cloud Spanner?
You get a fully managed system.
So that is important
not to forget.
So you don't need
to do any upgrades.
You don't have downtimes.
You don't have downtimes
within the SLA.
You don't have any software
patching that you have to do.
You don't have to
do any resharding.
All this is done for you.
We do the load balancing.
We do the optimizations
of the splits and things
like that behind the scenes
based on your traffic patterns.
And really important is
you get strong consistency
across a horizontally
distributed system.
So true asset capabilities
and strong consistency,
which is the highest
guarantee of consistency
that you have out there.
So we don't believe in choosing
your consistency level.
We just give you the highest.
So what to consider.
This is basically
the planning phase.
So these are the things
that you have to consider.
Is the application that you're
running right now, is it
suitable to move?
How much do I have to
invest in terms of work?
What work do I have
to invest in terms
of schema changes, application
changes, things like that?
Now, if you decide
and say, yes, there
are all these benefits
that come with it,
and I want to move
under Cloud Spanner,
here are a couple of ideas
how to approach this.
So number one, and that
might sound very simplistic,
but I still want to
put it out there,
the easiest way to move your
application to Cloud Spanner
is to bundle all your database
access code into one module.
So with that, you can do
a lot of amazing things.
You can basically isolate
the testing for that module.
You can optimize around that
module in terms of latency,
in terms of contention,
in terms of ACLs
that you can implement
in this model.
So it makes it
much easier, if you
have the possibility
in your application,
to isolate the DB access code
and move that all into one
module, so that it makes the
transition from your old system
to the new system much
more straightforward.
So now, how would
you do that in terms
of getting your data over?
One possibility is
to use Cloud Dataflow
or use a backup that you can
use on MySQL or PostgreSQL
or on your favorite database
system that you're using.
So basically, we do
a backup into files.
They can have different formats.
If it is CSV, if it is Avro, if
it's Parquet, it's up to you.
And then you move that
basically into Cloud Storage,
into a Cloud Storage
packet, and then from there
you use the recommended ways
to use Cloud Dataflow to load
this data into Cloud Spanner.
And I'm going to
show a little bit.
Please switch in a
second to my laptop.
If I remember of my password Oh.
Whew.
OK.
Let's do caffeine, which
I would need as well.
So what I want to
show here is, if you
want to get started with
Dataflow to load data
into your Cloud
Spanner instance,
we have actually some Dataflow
templates available for you
that you can look
into and basically
take as an inspiration or even
modify it in a way as you want.
So on GitHub, on the Google
Cloud Platform organization,
you'll find Dataflow templates.
And as you can see
here, we have a bunch
of templates which allow
you to basically export
into, for instance,
Avro, CSV, or text files,
and then also load from GCS
text into Cloud Spanner.
So this is a good
place to start.
And these are
actually the templates
that we are also using for
our self-managed backup
that you have available.
So I want to show
that really quickly.
So what is possible
is actually here
I have a bunch of my instances
that are running right now.
I have done already a restore.
So I'm going to show
that in a second.
But basically, what you can do
is you can go onto a database,
click the Export button,
select the bucket where
you want to export it.
So I have here my
ticketshop-backups.
I can select this.
Go all through this.
Select the database
you want to export.
Select the region.
You want to select the region
where that instance is actually
living.
And it shows you which
one is recommended.
Confirm all the changes,
and then you do the export.
For this example, for
this database that
has around 120
gigabytes of data,
it took about 20 minutes
to export this data.
So let me show how that looks
like when I actually get that
back.
And it doesn't show
me, unfortunately.
So I'm going to show right here.
I hope it is possible
to show that.
Let's go to Dataflow.
So here you see the
export job that we did.
And it's basically creating
all this behind the scenes.
You saw here it showed
right now one hour and 40,
but that is actually not the
actual time, the while time
that it took.
It is the aggregated time
through all the instances
that were used.
So if you look at
the elapsed time,
we have that here
on the right, which
shows 22 minutes, for doing
that backup for our set,
like, 120 gigabytes.
Now, if you go into
the Import, again, I
can show the dialog in a second.
It's very easy.
You pick basically the folder
where you exported it to,
and then it creates the
database schema automatically
and then loads into this data.
Now, some might spot there
is a green line over here
and the blue line
over here, and they
don't match up, which is
usually not a good sign.
And that is also the
reason why we see here
it took an hour to
restore that data.
Again, this can
be improved a lot
by having sufficient quota
for your Dataflow jobs.
So as you can see here, I
didn't have a sufficient quota.
So at around 25 workers, I
was maxed out on my quota.
And the green line is
actually the suggested scaling
of the Dataflow job in terms
of nodes that are helping
or workers that are
helping loading this data.
So if I would have
had more quota,
this restore job would
have gone much faster.
But again, it's
not something that
is automated in the
background for us
in terms of how do you schedule.
You have to schedule your
own backups and restores
if you want to use this.
So let me go back really quick.
So how would that look like
if you have, for instance,
an instance running here?
You would go to your
bucket, ticketshop-backups.
Select the folder.
For instance, let's say, demo01.
Select the region, confirm,
import, and then it
basically, again,
creates this Dataflow job
you see here already.
The schema is created.
And in a second,
it should come up
that we have this Dataflow job.
You can go here, look at
it, and it creates that all
behind the scenes, and I don't
need to do anything more.
Let's switch back to
the slides, please.
So if you don't want to use
the Dataflow job to load
your data into
Cloud Spanner, you
want to run your own
import into Cloud Spanner,
there are a couple
of best practices
that you want to look at.
Number one, what we see a lot
is you create a new instance,
you create a new
database, and then you
throw all the load basically
against that database.
What you will see is
that in the beginning,
it will take a while to actually
catch up and scale nicely.
And the reason for this is
you create your new instance
and new database
with your schema,
all your tables are
empty, and all your tables
have exactly one split.
So up to the point
that we actually
have a nice splitting of the
tables, which can accommodate
the load, you will see
basically not your best
possible performance.
So if you actually want to
move over your live data,
your production data in
a really quick manner
from your old system to the
new system, what we recommend
is that you create your
database, the schema,
and then load it with
generated data or with some--
maybe you can use a backup
to preload that database.
Then delete all the data,
and then load the actual data
that you want to
load into there.
The reason is, with
preloading your database,
you're basically
pre-warming all the splits,
and that enables it to go
much faster than you actually
need the higher performance.
Second thing is group and
batch multiple rows together
in a transaction.
The optimal size, between
1 and 10 megabytes.
And we have a limitation
of 20,000 mutations.
This is a hard limitation.
We won't remove that for
the foreseeable future.
So you have to stay in this
20,000 mutations range.
What is a mutation?
A mutation is any cell change
that you have in your tables.
So imagine you have a table
with five columns and three
primary keys.
And then you have
another index, which
is using the primary keys,
just in a different order.
And let's say, also, for
all the three primary keys.
Actually, for any row that you
insert into that base table,
you have eight mutations.
Five are coming
from your base table
and three are coming
from the index table.
So have that in mind, like,
if you have a lot of indexes
in there and you want to load
a lot of data into your table,
you might run quickly into the
20,000 mutations limitation.
Then if you do the batching
and loading into Cloud Spanner,
this might sound
counterintuitive, but actually,
order your data that you want
to load into Cloud Spanner
by primary key, and then split
it up into distinct ranges,
and then send these distinct
ranges to Cloud Spanner.
That gives you the
best throughput
to load into Cloud Spanner
and then, of course,
scale out your import processes.
So two types of
migrations that we can do.
Number one, of course, is
doing an application migration
with downtime.
So here, basically, you
have your application
talking to your original DB.
You do all the export, and
import it into Cloud Spanner.
You have your new
application ready.
And so you turn your application
down, then you do the backup,
and restore into Cloud Spanner.
And then you turn the
new application on
and let the new application
speak to Cloud Spanner.
Simple, but with downtime.
Now, it's a little
bit more complicated
if you actually want
to have a system that
runs without
downtime and you want
to have an online migration,
then you do all the schema
adoption as well.
You deploy your new
application basically,
which has both versions,
can speak to the old
and to the new database.
You do an export, which
is basically the preload,
while your application
still uses the original DB
as the original source
of truth, and then
you implement basically
a Dataflow job,
for instance, which does
the change data capturing
from your original database
into Cloud Spanner.
And as soon as they basically
catch up and they are in sync,
you can flip the switch and
let your application talk
to the Cloud Spanner,
and hit the Launch button
and have a launch party,
and cross the fingers
that everything works fine.
So in summary, isolate DB
code, do the schema updates
upfront with the best
practices that I mentioned,
move your business logic
to the application,
run your old and new
databases in parallel
if you want to do the
online, and then basically do
the switch over.
And test that multiple
times before you do it
actually on your customers.
So that concludes
section one, planning.
Section two, how you
would efficiently
move your data to
the Cloud Spanner.
And the third one is monitoring,
inspecting, and optimizing.
So I have a couple of
demos that I show here.
Of course, again, I could
only pick very specific ones.
I would love to do an
entire session only
about the index modifications
and optimizations,
but I probably would
lose 80% of the room,
and that I want to avoid.
So I have concentrated
on something simple.
So I want to set
the stage first.
So this is the stage
that I want to set.
So this is a schema.
It's fairly straightforward.
I designed this schema for
the 2017 launch keynote demo
for Cloud Spanner.
So you can see, we
reuse things sometimes.
I love to reuse this schema.
It allows me to do a couple
of really nice demos.
So what we have here is--
what I created as
a demo application
is like a simulated ticket shop.
And a ticket shop basically
uses a global distributed,
multi-regional, global
Spanner instance.
And you can buy tickets in
a strong, consistent manner
from all over the world.
The cool thing here
is I am not going
to sell a ticket twice, which
happens for some airlines,
I heard, and other places, which
is not necessarily the best
thing to have for your customer,
when they are standing in front
of the airplane door
and you are not allowed
in because the airplane's full.
So a strong,
consistent system here
can help greatly if you actually
can sell the tickets exactly
that you want.
Now, some might walk up
to me afterwards and say,
they do that on purpose.
I know they do that on
purpose, because there
are a lot of people
that don't show up.
Now, what do I want to show?
I have three tables
that we're going to look
at a little bit more in detail.
I have my Venue table.
So I have 1,000 venues
all over the world
that I generated artificially.
I have a Seating category.
It looks much better on
this display than on this.
I have the
SeatingCategory there,
which basically tells me, like,
is this a general seating?
Is this a VIP seating?
Is it a lounge?
Is it a saloon?
Do you get dinner with it?
Something like that.
And then I have
the actual tickets.
So the tickets basically
are the tickets.
In that case, I have
pre-created these tickets,
so that I just need
to flip some bits if I
want to sell a ticket.
So the commonalities in these
tables are, in my Venue table,
I have 1,000 venues.
In my seating categories, I
have 2,655 seating categories,
so roughly 2.6 seating
categories per venue.
And that's an average.
There are some venues which
only have one seating category.
There are others
which have five.
And then I have my tickets.
If I can count correctly,
this is about 20,000 tickets
that I have in my database.
Now, what I want to show
is I want to basically do
optimization of an index.
So what I'm going
to show first is
I'm going to show
a query that I have
run, which I started actually
before I started this talk.
And so you can see,
to explain the query,
I want to know how many tickets
are available in the Berlin Old
Club, which is my venue name.
So to find out, I basically
have to go to my venue,
join it with my SeatingCategory,
join it with the Ticket table,
and then do the select.
And the ones that are
familiar over here
in this room with SQL,
they cringe probably
right now the way that
I've written this query.
And I've written that
on purpose this way.
So basically, what
you see here is
I'm doing a join from my
SeatingCategory onto the Ticket
table and then onto the Venue.
So now, I could make
that even worse.
If I would switch
and say, I want
to join from my Ticket
table to my SeatingCategory
and then to the Venue, my
query wouldn't actually finish.
It times out.
I tested.
Trust me.
It times out.
And so I did the second
worst option here.
I basically take
my SeatingCategory,
join my Ticket,
and join the Venue.
The problem that
we have here is I
have a pretty big
cardinality table
that I joined basically in
the beginning and the smaller
cardinality table
towards the end.
As you can see here,
this took four minutes
to basically finish.
And I have a couple
of things that
are actually pretty nice here.
So you see the rows scanned,
how much CPU time I'm using.
It shows you basically the query
plan here that you can see,
OK, I'm doing a table
scan on the Venue,
then I'm using an index on
the SeatingCategory, which
is already good.
I'm using an index on my
Ticket table, which is good,
but I'm still going
through all my tickets.
So in the end, it's fairly slow.
So I want to show the power
of actually improving just
by reordering the
way that you are
joining your tables together.
So in this case, I'm
doing the better thing.
So always, as a
rule of thumb, begin
with the smallest cardinality
table if you do joins.
So here I'm starting
with my Venue table,
and then join the
SeatingCategory,
Ticket table on it.
So now if we run it,
we're going to see
it will take still
a little bit while,
if the demo gods are with me,
and it will show in a second.
I think it should be
around 25 seconds.
But basically, you see here,
that's still not great.
It's only 1,000 venues.
This should go much faster.
What is happening here?
Oh, 15 seconds.
That is awesome.
So we went down from 240
seconds to 15 seconds
just by reordering the joins.
So think about that.
If you run into problems, into
issues, into latency and query
times issues, look at,
what are the cardinalities
of your tables?
We know a great optimizer
does that automatically.
We don't have the
greatest optimizer yet.
We are working on it.
But there's still a little bit
of manual labor involved here
if you want to get
good query times.
Now, as you can
see, we are still
scanning 20 million rows here,
which is still way too much.
It takes us 15 seconds
to actually do this.
So what I did is--
I hope this is the right one.
What I did, actually, I
looked at the Ticket table
and saw, like,
OK, can I actually
create an index which
helps me in this?
So I created an index
which is on the CategoryId,
because I want to join
with my SeatingCategory.
And then I have the TicketId,
so I can join the Ticket table
onto it.
And then you see something
else in the bottom.
So I have some more data
actually in the bottom.
And so what I can
do in this index is,
I can actually declare
what I want to index on,
and then I can
attach data to it.
So this is the STORING clause
that I mentioned earlier.
So if we show the
DDL, you can see here,
you basically have
this STORING clause,
and that allows you
to basically attach
some data to your primary
key in this index.
And that is very helpful.
Now, some might ask, why do
I do it in storing and not
into the primary key?
There can be multiple reasons.
Number one is you
change actually
the ordering of your
index if you put them
into the primary key
of the index columns.
So that is something
to consider.
There are some other things
that are behind the scenes which
are considered, basically,
if they are indexed columns
versus stored columns.
So now let's have a look at
the query, how it runs here.
And as we can see, it runs
now in 100 milliseconds,
gives me the same data back.
There is 1,650 seats
in my Berlin Old Club.
And if we look at how many
rows were actually scanned,
there were only 1,652 scans.
So we scanned two rows too much.
We still have potential
for improvement here.
But as you can see, we went down
from 20 million rows and 240
seconds, and I didn't even
do the worst kind of query,
down to milliseconds by
creating the right indices
and using the right join
order for your queries.
So let's switch
back to the slides.
So I want to repeat
again on the indexes,
because it's something
that is often forgotten.
If you do have indexes and
use the STORING clause,
you basically avoid
with the Storing clause
to do a back-join
against the base table.
So query is where you do select
star of something really bad.
Really bad.
So don't do a select star.
Be really focused on
these, in your select,
what columns you really need.
And then if you expect
or hope an index
to be used for
your queries, make
sure that the index
has all the columns
that you need for your query.
So as soon as there's
one column not available,
you create the back-join
to the base table.
Another thing that
we see often is
in an index where
you define an index,
and then you use a subprimary
key or subindex columns,
but you don't use the prefix.
So let's say, you do
have a primary key, ABC,
and you index on
BCA, and then you
do a query on C. It basically
can't use your index.
You have to basically go back to
your table and do a table scan.
So make sure that
in your queries,
you use the same prefix of
indexed columns for both.
And in terms of locks, in
terms of complex transactions,
make sure that the locks are
on the range and column level.
So make sure that you restrict
that to the actually only used
and needed data.
So if you do a large range,
you lock the entire table.
So make sure that
the ranges are small
in your complex transactions.
The way to do that is
actually to do a query first
to get IDs or get primary
key ranges for the things
where you want to actually
write data to, and then
do that in your
read-write transaction
to really restrict that.
And also, to get the
benefit of caching,
make sure that you use something
like bounded parameters.
Another thing that is
helpful to understand
is to see how transactions
and locking is
working in Cloud Spanner.
So I want to dive into
two types of transactions
that Cloud Spanner
is supporting.
Number one is the
single split write.
For a single split write, the
advantage here is what we have,
if you do actually
a blind write,
we can actually
sequence your writes,
and we can share the
write lock on that split.
And that is really powerful.
We basically just use TrueTime,
which is our global clock
time that we use
in Cloud Spanner,
to sequence your
transaction, and we still
have strong consistency and
don't lock on your writes.
So how does it work here?
You see here, we have
the Spanner front end.
It's the API front end
that your client talks to.
That does a zone lookup
and a split lookup
on where the split lives.
This is usually
very heavily cached.
So the second time that
it comes in the front end,
it will respond to that already.
So this happens very
rarely, actually,
the first two lines
that you see there.
Then we send the
commit requests.
We acquire a write log.
We assign a TrueTime timestamp.
We are waiting out the
time till that upper bound
has passed basically.
And during that time, we
send a persist request
to the replicas, which are also
responsible for that split.
As soon as the majority comes
back, we basically send--
we wait for the TrueTime to
pass, and then respond back
that it was successful.
Now, in the multi-split
write, what we
have here is a scenario where
I do a read on the key 100,
and then I do a write
to key 100, 300,
and 400 for the values
ABC respectively.
And so what I do here, again,
we do the Spit Leader lookup.
So we have a couple
of splitters.
In this case, I have
the Split Leader
in zone A and split
zero, which gives me
my data for the
row of the key 100.
And it acquires a read lock.
Then we do the lookups
for the other keys
where we want to write to.
We send the commit request
to the Split Leaders.
And while we are doing this,
we choose one coordinator
for this transaction,
who is basically
the chef for this transaction.
And we tag all
these Split Leaders
as part of this transaction.
So now, the first
thing that we do,
because we want to
write to key 100, is we
actually have to
check if we still
have the read lock
on 100, and we have
to elevate it to a write lock.
Now, if there's any
conflicts, any possibility
of a deadlock, what we
do is a wait and wound.
So basically,
younger transactions
are boarded and restarted.
Older transactions are the
ones that are succeeding.
So once we have all
the request lock,
this is basically
the first phase
of the two-phase
commit protocol.
We can push the data out
to our split replicas
and acknowledge, of course,
that we have the locks.
Assign a timestamp.
Again, replicate to the
other replicas of the splits.
And then everybody
is coming back
with the commit for
this transaction.
And once we have all the commit
transactions notifications,
we wait out the
TrueTime timestamp
and then give the success
transaction back to the client.
I have one minute left.
I don't know if I get cut off
in my audio when I run over.
So I want to do a really
quick demo, because I think
it is actually fairly powerful.
So let's see if I
get that working.
So I do need to do
a couple of things.
Number one is here I
have Grafana running.
And what I'm using
here, just to explain it
in very simple terms, is
I use the YCSB workload.
And let me see.
I actually need to
fix something here.
Generate some data.
So what I have is,
in Kubernetes, I
have some clients running,
which use the YCSB
schema of user
table, and I'm going
to write to these user tables.
So let's do demo03, and
then I also do demo04.
So what this is doing
here is nothing else
than I'm sending a pop-up
message, actually, which
my clients are listening to.
And they can get instructions
through this pop-up message.
And the pop-up
message here says,
I want to do random reads with
a target of 50 per client,
and I want to do
random stale reads
with a target of 50 per client.
And we're running that against
two different instances.
I want to show you the
power of unbounded reads.
So one thing that we also
see is if you sometimes
see even a read-only
transaction,
but a read-only
strong transaction,
if it conflicts with your write,
it could sometimes end up slow.
So if you have the possibility
to do time-bounded queries
where you allow a
little bit of staleness,
even if it's less than a second
or a second of staleness,
if you can accommodate
that in your application,
do this, because it will speed
up your queries tremendously
and helps basically
with lock contention
if you see things like that.
So what do we have here?
Let me update this.
Let's see if Grafana
is still happy with me.
It looks like it's still happy.
So we see here, right
now it's starting to run.
So this was on a cold instance.
It hasn't done much
for hours, basically.
And I just started
this workload.
And then what you
can see here is,
basically, I have
clients in Asia,
in Europe, and in
the United States
which are sending write
requests against the database.
So you can see here, in the
US, it's 33 milliseconds.
In Asia, it's 210
round trip time.
And then Europe is 88.
So this is just
single cell writes.
So this is basically
law of physics latency.
These are strong reads.
So I always have to
check against the leader
of that split if I
have the latest data.
Now, if I do time-bounded,
you see, there
is not much difference here.
The reason here is, this
is actually in the S--
that instance.
It doesn't have
replicas globally.
It just have basically
multi-region US.
So you still have
to go to the US
to get your data if you
look at the latencies
from Asia or from Europe.
Now, let me show what
that means if you actually
use a multi-regional
global database.
Here in this case-- and I want
to zoom in to actually show you
this a little bit nicer.
So what do we have here?
Here I have a global database
where I have read-only replicas
in Asia and in Europe.
So you see that the
times for reading strong
is still about the same.
It's a little lower,
as you can see.
So sometimes you just don't
need to move any data.
You need just to check if you
still have the latest data.
And then you do the random read.
So 10 milliseconds.
From Asia, 166.
From Europe, about 100.
But then we go down here.
And as you can see
here, I do time-bounded,
and they are all about
nine milliseconds.
So that is that
power of time-bounded
reads with Cloud Spanner.
Moving to the related
sessions, just two things
that I want to point out.
Today at 3:30 and then
tomorrow at 10:20,
there are two more
sessions on Spanner.
Really interesting.
The first one is Andrew
Fikes, the VP of engineering.
And then the second
one is showing
how Google Cloud Storage has
actually built the metadata
services built on
top of Cloud Spanner,
and what qualities
gives that to you.
And with that, there are
a couple of resources.
The best one is
cloud.google.com/spanner.
It gives you basically an
entry point into everything.
If you want to learn a little
bit about optimizations,
I have a video series under
"TIL about Cloud Spanner."
So today, "Things I Learned
About Cloud Spanner," what
you can see here basically.
And then last but not
least, please, please
rate this session, if you liked
it, if you didn't like it,
if you want to see
something else.
Every feedback is welcome.
But be nice and
constructive, please.
And with that, thank you
very much for joining
and have a great day.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]